All right, guys. We're here. Don't forget your stuff, OK? And Dylan, grab your snow pants.
好了，各位。我们到了。别忘了带上你们的东西，好吗？还有迪伦，带上你的防雪裤。
OK.
好的。
Here's a ritual that happens in millions of American families every day, parents dropping off kids at the babysitter's.
这是每天在数百万美国家庭中都会上演的仪式，父母把孩子送到保姆家。
Good morning.
早上好。
Hi, sweetie. I haven't seen you guys in such a long time.
嗨，宝贝。我好久没见到你们了。
Sarah, age 9, and Dylan, who's 6, are being left at a friend's house where there are two other kids, Elliott and Emma, and their regular babysitter, Cristiana, who meets them at the door, who hasn't seen them since before Christmas.
9岁的萨拉和6岁的迪伦被留在了朋友家，那里还有另外两个孩子，埃利奥特和艾玛，以及他们固定的保姆克里斯蒂安娜。克里斯蒂安娜在门口迎接他们，自从圣诞节前她就没见过他们了。
These kids have known Cristiana longer than they've known almost anyone. Four years she's been their sitter, an eternity. Cristiana takes care of them after school every day. Cristiana knows everything about them. And their such old pros at being left with the sitter, they don't think twice about it. Mom leaves, no tears, no scenes.
这些孩子认识克里斯蒂安娜的时间比认识几乎任何人都长。她当他们的保姆四年了，这简直是永恒。克里斯蒂安娜每天放学后都照顾他们。她了解关于他们的一切。他们对于被留给保姆照顾已经是老手了，对此毫不在意。妈妈离开时，没有泪水，没有闹剧。
All right, bye. I love you. I love you, be good.
好了，再见。我爱你们。我爱你们，要乖哦。
Cristiana serves cereal to the four kids. Emma gets the Powerpuff Girl bowl. Sarah gets the Barbie bowl. And Dylan and Sarah fill me in on the differences between Cristiana and their other main babysitter, a college student named Natalia.
克里斯蒂安娜为四个孩子准备了麦片。艾玛拿到了飞天小女警的碗。萨拉拿到了芭比碗。迪伦和萨拉向我介绍了克里斯蒂安娜和他们另一位主要保姆——一位名叫娜塔莉亚的大学生之间的区别。
She's not as cool as Cristiana and everything.
她没有克里斯蒂安娜那么酷。
Like if you want to get away with something, who is it easier to get away with, Cristiana or Natalia?
比如如果你们想耍点小聪明，谁比较容易糊弄？克里斯蒂安娜还是娜塔莉亚？
Natalia.
娜塔莉亚。
She doesn't really know the rules of our house. So then, I say we can drink coke, and then--
她不太了解我们家的规矩。所以，我说我们可以喝可乐，然后——
You say you can wear your clothes to bed all the time. Mom lets me wear my clothes to bed, for like half a year that you would do that at the babysitter's.
你说你可以一直穿着衣服睡觉。妈妈让我穿着衣服睡觉，有大半年你都是在保姆那儿这么做的。
And why do you want to go to bed in your clothes?
为什么你想穿着衣服睡觉？
Because then, I don't have to change.
因为那样我就不用换衣服了。
He doesn't like changing. He thinks it wastes too much time.
他不喜欢换衣服。他认为那太浪费时间了。
With Cristiana, it's different. She's like a second mom.
和克里斯蒂安娜在一起就不一样了。她就像第二个妈妈。
That's what she thinks.
那是她自以为的。
I think of you guys as my kids.
我把你们当成我自己的孩子。
Yeah.
没错。
I know them, I've known them since they were all so little. And I love them like that. Yeah, and these guys, I've just been seeing them growing up, and growing bigger, and learning things, and I'm just very, very attached to them.
我了解他们，从他们都很小的时候我就认识他们了。我像爱自己的孩子一样爱他们。是的，看着他们长大，变得更高，学习各种知识，我真的非常、非常依恋他们。
When a mom shows up at the house a little later to drop off yet another child, she doesn't use the word mom to describe Cristiana. Mom, that's her territory. The word she uses is aunt.
当一位妈妈稍晚一点赶到家里送另一个孩子时，她没有用“妈妈”这个词来称呼克里斯蒂安娜。妈妈，那是她的专属领地。她用的词是“阿姨”。
How do you define this job, watching children for money? Well, today on our program, babysitters, and what exactly happens when mom and dad are out of sight. Our show today in three acts. In the first, an older brother babysits, and the younger brothers cower. Act two is about a day in 1988 when huge companies accidentally found themselves taking on a massive babysitting job because of snow.
你如何定义这份为了钱照顾孩子的工作？好吧，今天我们的节目主题是保姆，当爸爸妈妈不在视线范围内时，究竟会发生什么。我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，哥哥当保姆，弟弟们吓得瑟瑟发抖。第二幕讲的是1988年的一天，大型航空公司因为大雪意外地承担了一项巨大的保姆工作。
In act three, a brother and sister get a job babysitting for some children who do not exist. And before we say anything else about babysitters, first let's just have a little brief word, just you and me, about Mary Poppins. Mary Poppins, let's just say right here, she is the gold standard of all fictional babysitters, maybe of all real ones too.
第三幕，兄妹俩为根本不存在的孩子打工当保姆。在说保姆的事之前，让我们先简短地聊聊玛丽·波平斯。玛丽·波平斯，我们就在这儿下个定论，她是所有虚构保姆中的黄金标准，或许也是所有现实保姆的标准。
She is the one that all others are to be measured by. And the movie, Mary Poppins, it contains what is probably the classic song about babysitting. You remember, the kids in the film sing about what it is that they want in a babysitter.
她是衡量所有人的标杆。电影《玛丽·波平斯》里有一首关于保姆的经典歌曲。还记得吗，电影里的孩子们唱着他们想要的保姆是什么样的。
[SONG - THE PERFECT NANNY, MARY POPPINS]
[歌曲 - 完美的保姆，《玛丽·波平斯》]
Let me just stop this right here. This is not exactly the tone that we are going for in today's radio program. Let's cut through the treacle.
让我在这儿打断一下。这可不是我们今天广播节目想要的基调。让我们抛开这些甜腻的东西。
[SONG - THE PERFECT NANNY, MARY POPPINS]
[歌曲 - 完美的保姆，《玛丽·波平斯》]
Music recorded for our program by The Dishes. Engineering by Elliot Dix and Mike Segal at Engine Music Studios. Which brings us to Act 1.
本节目音乐由The Dishes录制。工程由Engine Music Studios的艾略特·迪克斯和迈克·西格尔负责。现在进入第一幕。
Lots of babysitting is done by family members. In this first story, parents leave their kids in the care of their teenage son, but instead of acting as a surrogate parent, standing above sibling squabbles and rivalries, acting as judge and mediator, the teenage babysitter stays squarely in the center of those rivalries. But as ruler and king, now with no parental forces tempering his actions, Hillary Frank has this cautionary tale about what happened.
很多保姆工作是由家庭成员完成的。在第一个故事里，父母把孩子交给十几岁的儿子照顾，但这名保姆并没有像代理父母那样置身事外、调解手足争端，而是直接卷入了这些冲突中。他像个君主一样行使权力，没有父母的约束，希拉里·弗兰克带来了这个关于当时发生了什么的警示故事。
The Perrys grew up in rural Idaho. When their parents went out, the oldest son, Doug, was left in charge of his four younger siblings. Doug was the kind of guy who ruled the last three rows of the school bus through a combination of force and psychological pressure.
佩里一家在爱达荷州的农村长大。父母外出时，大儿子道格负责照顾四个年幼的弟妹。道格是个能通过武力和心理施压统治校车最后三排的家伙。
He told other kids that the bus driver signed an agreement, putting him in charge of the back of the bus. He wore a bomber jacket. He rode a motorcycle. Still, his parents thought he seemed responsible enough when it came to his brothers and sister. There was a lot they didn't know.
他告诉其他孩子校车司机签了协议，让他管理车尾。他穿着轰炸机夹克，骑着摩托车。尽管如此，他父母仍认为他在照顾弟妹方面足够负责。他们不知道的事情还有很多。
If I had to be there tending to these dang kids, I was going to make it fun for me too, you know.
如果我非得待在那里照顾这些讨厌的小鬼，那我也得给自己找点乐子，你懂的。
Doug often subjected his three little brothers to what he calls bravery tests. He would do things like stuff them in a sleeping bag and tie them to a tree limb, or snap huge rubber bands at their skin until they stopped flinching.
道格经常对他三个小弟弟进行所谓的“勇气测试”。他会把他们塞进睡袋里绑在树枝上，或者用巨大的橡皮筋弹他们的皮肤，直到他们不再退缩。
I really hesitate to tell this, because it could have been-- I mean, it's just-- well, anyway, we had this iguana, OK, this big lizard, about-- it was about three feet long. It died. Well, I was so attached to this thing that I, of course, didn't want to take it out and bury it.
我真不想说这个，因为它可能——我是说，它就是——好吧，总之，我们当时有只鬣蜥，你知道，那只大蜥蜴，大概三英尺长。它死了。好吧，我当时太舍不得它了，所以当然不想把它拿出去埋了。
So I put it in the freezer and kept it. Well, this is a fun thing for all of us boys to take out of the freezer, and thaw out, and play with it, you know. And then we got tired of playing with it. And then we'd put it back in the freezer, you know, and we'd freeze it again.
于是我把它放进冰箱里保存着。这成了我们几个男孩的乐子，把它从冰箱里拿出来，解冻，玩弄它。等玩腻了，我们就把它放回冰箱，再把它冻起来。
And after about a year and a half of this, we decided we needed a new bravery test. So we thought what can we do, hmm. I think we should boil and eat-- boil and eat the iguana. That would be the ultimate bravery test.
这样过了大概一年半，我们决定需要一个新的勇气测试。所以我们想，能做什么呢？我想我们应该把那只鬣蜥煮了吃掉。那将是终极的勇气测试。
Well, we put it in a pot. We brought the biggest pot my mom had, and we stuffed it in there, and boiled it, you know. Well, well, it's been boiling about five minutes, probably done by now. And we got the thing out, and honest to goodness, we ate some of that lizard.
我们把它放进锅里，拿了我妈最大的锅，把它塞进去，煮了。煮了大概五分钟，可能已经熟了。我们把它拿出来，说实话，我们真的吃了一些那只蜥蜴。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I even ate some.
连我都吃了一些。
Really?
真的吗？
And they even ate some.
他们也吃了一些。
What did it taste like?
那是什么味道？
You know, at that point, it actually tasted kind of like sawdust.
你知道，那个时候，尝起来其实有点像锯末。
Doug did all the bravery tests he made his brothers do. He was right in there with them. But they were on their own when it came to one of Doug's long running babysitting pranks. I spoke with Doug, and with his youngest brother, Mike, who was the easiest target. They're 10 years apart.
道格自己也做了他让弟弟们做的那些勇气测试。他身先士卒。但对于道格长期的“保姆恶作剧”，他们只能自求多福。我采访了道格和他最小的弟弟迈克，迈克是最容易被欺负的目标。他们相差10岁。
We were convinced that he-- we were convinced for three or four years of our lives, I think, that he could actually turn into a werewolf. We would walk out of the house and then you'd hear this-- [HOWLS] and it would literally stop you in your tracks. And you just knew he was out there somewhere.
我们当时深信——我觉得我们在生活中坚信了三四年——他真的能变成狼人。我们走出屋子，然后就会听到这种——[嚎叫]，这真的会让你停下脚步。你知道他就潜伏在某处。
Again, here's Doug.
再听听道格怎么说。
We had a pasture in the back, and it was about maybe half an acre. And they'd go out clear to the back fence, and that's where they liked to sleep out. So this is the perfect place for me to stalk them in the night, you know, and sneak up, and be the werewolf.
我们后面有个牧场，大概半英亩。他们喜欢跑到后栅栏那里露宿。所以那是我在夜里跟踪他们、偷偷潜伏并扮成狼人的绝佳场所。
So I would kind of just crawl out into the shadows. And I could hear them out there talking. And I'd be sneaking up through the bushes, and I'd go-- [HOWLS] And I'd hear dead silence. And then I'd hear one of them go, Doug's a werewolf.
所以我就偷偷爬进阴影里。我可以听到他们在外面说话。我在灌木丛中溜过去，然后喊——[嚎叫]。接着我听到死一般的寂静。然后听到其中一个说，道格是狼人。
Doug kept this up for years, and the kids began to dread it, whenever their parents went out, knowing something scary would happen them, until finally, it all came to a head one night. Mike was eight years old. The middle brothers were 11 and 13. Doug was 18. It began the way it usually did, out in a pasture surrounded by potato fields. Here's Doug.
道格玩了好几年，孩子们只要看到父母出门就开始害怕，知道肯定会有什么可怕的事情发生，直到有一天晚上，一切爆发了。迈克当时8岁。中间的弟弟们分别是11岁和13岁。道格18岁。事情开始得和平时一样，在马铃薯田环绕的牧场里。听听道格怎么说。
We had a full moon, which was wonderful. And I kind of got to where the moon was silhouetting me, and they couldn't really see me. And I stuck a bunch of weeds down in my glasses, so they were poking out all around, and then I kind of rose up out of the weed patch.
那天是满月，真是太棒了。我站在月光刚好能照出我轮廓的地方，他们看不清我。我把一把杂草插进我的眼镜里，草尖到处乱翘，然后我从杂草丛中站起来。
And they could see the silhouette with all this, looked like hair, poking out, you know, so that convinced them. I mean, totally-- I was totally growing hair. I was completely a werewolf. So run for your life, you know.
他们能看到那个轮廓，加上那些乱草，看起来就像头发一样，这让他们深信不疑。我是说，彻底相信——我确实在长毛。我完全是个狼人了。所以大家快逃命吧。
And we all, of course, knew that the best thing to do was to get out of our sleeping bags and run as fast as we could to the house because that was the sure shelter.
我们当然觉得最好的办法就是爬出睡袋，以最快的速度跑回屋里，因为那是安全的庇护所。
What were you afraid that Doug was going to do to you?
你当时怕道格会对你做什么？
Well, it's just the whole idea of being chased around in the dark. And it's not like there was ever a lack of physical contact. I mean, he-- literally was a situation where you were scared for your life. And we knew that Doug was in between us and the house somewhere.
就是那种在黑暗中被追赶的感觉。而且从来都不缺乏身体接触。我是说，情况确实让你感到生命受到了威胁。我们知道道格就在我们和屋子之间的某个地方。
And as we were running to the house, Doug was just sitting on the roof in a sort of a gargoyle position, just as still as the night, and just staring at us, watching us. And so we just kind of slowly, kind of just walked, underneath him and ran into the house.
当我们跑向屋子时，道格正像个石像鬼一样蹲在屋顶上，一动不动，像黑夜一样安静，就那样盯着我们，看着我们。所以我们就慢慢地从他下面溜过去，跑进了屋里。
Well now, I'm peeking in the windows. I'm rattling the doors more. I'm trying to get in. And they're running from door to door, trying to lock all the doors up. And I was always right on their heels, as they made it to the door. And I made sure that I just didn't quite catch them, you know. And they would run in to slam the doors.
现在，我在窗外窥视。我更用力地晃动房门。我想进去。他们在各个门之间奔跑，试图锁好所有的门。我总是紧跟在他们身后。我确保没让他们抓到，你知道。他们跑进去猛地关上门。
Just about the time they thought they were all safe, I snuck over and took the breaker, I shut the breaker off to the house. And then all of a sudden, the lights go out. And it's pitch dark in the house. It was like this-- we're all going to die. I mean, it was just, they had no safe place they could think of to go, until one of them finally thought get to the car, you know, we got to get in the car and lock the doors.
就在他们以为自己安全的时候，我溜过去拉下了断路器，关掉了屋子的电源。灯一下子全灭了。屋子里漆黑一片。就像是——我们要死了。他们觉得无处可逃，直到其中一个人终于想到去车里，他们说，我们得进车里锁上门。
And as we were all sitting in there, looking around at each other, we realized that my brother, Steve, didn't make it out of the house.
当我们坐在一起看着对方时，意识到我弟弟史蒂夫没能逃出来。
And then the next thing I know I'm in the house alone.
接下来我发现我独自在屋子里。
Let's introduce another brother. This is Steve.
让我们介绍另一位弟弟。这是史蒂夫。
Of course, my fear went out, you know, through the roof. And then, I see him look in, in the patio window at me.
当然，我的恐惧瞬间飙升到了极点。然后，我看到他从天井的窗户向我望进来。
Well, I was still around back, so I thought, well, Steve is still in there. I could see in the darkness, I could see him rocking in the chair. Well, I'll get Steve.
我当时还在后面，所以我心想，史蒂夫还在里面。我在黑暗中能看到他坐在椅子上摇晃。好，我去抓史蒂夫。
He snuck into the house. And he saw my brother, Steve, sitting on the couch. And Steve just said, I don't care, kill me if you want.
他溜进屋子，看见我弟弟史蒂夫坐在沙发上。史蒂夫只说了句，我不在乎，杀了我吧，随便你。
And that was when I told him, you know, just kill me or whatever, be done with it, however you want to end it. I mean, I'm done.
那就是我对他说，杀了我还是什么的，随你的便，不管你想怎么结束这一切。我是说，我受够了。
I don't think we ever played it again after that point.
我想在那之后我们就再也没玩过那个游戏了。
These days, the brothers are all quick to say that Doug was playing werewolf, that it was just a game. None of them carry resentment towards him. But when they were kids, clearly feelings were running a bit hotter. Around the same time that Doug had his little siblings convinced he wanted their blood, he got into a motorcycle accident that nearly killed him. He broke every bone in his face, one arm, and one irreplaceable kneecap. The force of the crash made the helmet, along with his scalp, shoot off his head. It took around 350 stitches to sew him back up.
如今，这几个兄弟很快就说，道格那时候只是在玩狼人游戏，那只是个游戏。他们没人对他怀恨在心。但他们小时候，感情显然要激烈得多。就在道格让弟妹们坚信他想要他们的血的同一时期，他出了一场摩托车事故，差点丧命。他脸上的骨头全断了，一只手臂骨折，膝盖骨碎裂。碰撞的力量导致头盔连同他的头皮一起飞了出去。医生缝了大约350针才把他缝好。
You know, when I came home from the hospital, I had my leg in a cast, my arm in a cast, I was in a wheelchair. My face was all banged up. And my brothers said, mom, we'll take Doug down the road in his wheelchair for a walk. And so he can have some air. And so she goes, OK. And I get in the wheelchair.
你知道，我从医院回家时，腿上打着石膏，胳膊打着石膏，坐着轮椅。脸也是肿的。我弟弟们说，妈妈，我们带道格坐轮椅去路上散散步，让他透透气。她说，好吧。于是我坐进轮椅。
They get me out on the highway and run as fast as they can, and then let go. And I'm like, [SCREAMS], you know, going down the road in the wheelchair, heading for the ditch. And just about the time I go in the ditch, they catch up to me and straighten me out and go again, you know. So this was kind of a get even-- get even with me kind of a time. And there was nothing I could do about it. And they had great fun with me that time, you know. I guess that, you know, I was expecting a lot of sympathy and poor Doug. And no, it wasn't that at all. It was let's get some revenge for all this.
他们把我推到高速公路上，跑得飞快，然后松开手。我心想，啊——，冲下公路，直奔沟里。就在我快掉进沟里时，他们赶上来扶正我，又开始推。所以这算是一种报复——这是他们报复我的时刻。我无能为力。他们玩得很开心。我猜我当时还期待他们能同情一下可怜的道格，但根本没有。那是为了报复以前的一切。
Revenge came in other forms as he got older. When Doug had kids of his own, to his horror, his oldest son, Corey, turned out to be exactly the same kind of babysitter that Doug had been. Doug would come home from a night out and find himself pulling Corey aside and saying things like next time, try and tie the rope a little looser around your brother's neck. Steve, the brother who told Doug, just kill me, is also a parent these days, of four daughters. And like Doug, he's had moments flashing back to the days when Doug babysat.
后来他长大后，报复以其他形式出现。道格有了自己的孩子后，令他恐惧的是，他的大儿子科里成了和他当保姆时一模一样的家伙。道格某晚回家，发现自己不得不把科里拉到一边，说些这样的话：下次，绳子绑在你弟弟脖子上时试着松一点。史蒂夫，那个曾对道格说“杀了我吧”的弟弟，如今也是四个女儿的父亲。像道格一样，他也会闪回道格当保姆的日子。
I remember this one time, he came out with his box, and he said look what I found out in the street. And he opened this box, and he has a finger sticking up through the bottom of the box, where all you could see was this bloody finger in there. I mean, I freaked out over that for years. I still remember it vividly. Of course, after he saw how freaked out we were about it, he showed us how it worked. I did it to my own kids, if you can believe that.
我记得有一次，他拿着一个盒子出来，说看看我在街上发现了什么。他打开盒子，里面伸出一根手指，穿过盒底，你只能看到那根血淋淋的手指。我为此惊恐了好多年。至今记忆犹新。当然，在他看到我们被吓成那样后，他演示了它是怎么工作的。我甚至对我自己的孩子也这么做了，如果你敢信的话。
You did?
你做了？
You know.
你知道的。
Why? Why would you want to freak them out like that?
为什么？你为什么想那样吓唬他们？
I don't know. I remembered it so vividly. And I thought, well that was-- and I think back on it, and I go well, it was kind of cool, actually, how he did it. So here I go, and I'm going to try it with my own kids, OK? And I lift up the box, and my oldest daughter just broke into tears. And I then-- I apologized all over myself for a week or two afterwards to her. I hope she's-- she's probably going to have as crappy a memory of that as I did when I seen it the first time, you know.
不知道。我记得太清楚了。我心想，这真的——回想起来，我觉得那其实挺酷的。所以我试着对我自己的孩子也这么做，结果呢？我抬起盒子，我大女儿直接哭了出来。接下来一两周里我都在不停地道歉。希望她——她对这件事的记忆可能和我第一次看到时一样糟糕。
Yeah, did you feel sort of like you were in Doug's shoes, like you knew what it felt like to be him?
是啊，你有没有觉得自己有点像道格，你理解那种作为他的感觉吗？
I catch myself wanting to tease them too, like he did, sometimes, in a fun sort of way. But my wife will go, you know, you're acting just like Doug.
我有时发现自己也想捉弄他们，像他那样，用一种有趣的方式。但我老婆会说，你现在的行为简直和道格一模一样。
As an adult, Doug has gone to each of his younger brothers and apologized for how he treated them. But he also thinks if they'd been less aggressive with each other as kids, they wouldn't be as close now.
成年后，道格向每个弟弟都道歉了，为他曾经对待他们的方式。但他也认为，如果他们小时候没那么激烈，他们现在也不会这么亲密。
I know families that have grown up more mellow than us, and they get along fine, and they're very civil, and they're very happy to see each other, but they're almost like when they see each other, they shake hands. And I'm like, give me a break. You haven't seen your brother for six months and you're shaking his hand?
我认识一些家庭，他们长大后比我们平和，他们相处得很好，非常客气，见面时很高兴，但他们几乎像是在见面时握手。我心想，饶了我吧。你六个月没见你兄弟，见面要握手？
I mean, we're grabbing each other and bearhugging, and we're jumping up and down, and it's a whole different relationship as far as I see, like people who've been through traumatic experiences together, you know. Maybe that's why. You feel like you've been through that, and survived it all together. And so it creates a deep bond or something maybe. So I think we're closer because of it, actually.
我是说，我们会搂在一起、熊抱，跳上跳下，那是一种完全不同的关系。就像一起经历过创伤性体验的人，你知道。也许这就是原因。你感觉你们一起经历过，并且活了下来。这产生了一种深厚的纽带。所以我认为我们反而因此更亲近了。
Did part of you know that when you were younger, that it might make you closer when you grew up?
你小时候是否部分意识到这可能会让你们长大后更亲近？
Well, you know, I think, maybe subconsciously it did, because after every time, you would feel somewhat closer. So I don't think as a kid you actually sit down and think if I do this, it's going to make me closer to my brother. You just do it if it feels that way, you know you just tend to do the things that make you grow closer together. And those are the things that we did that drew us together. So we continued doing those kind of things.
好吧，也许潜意识里是的，因为每次之后，你都会感到更亲近一点。我不认为作为孩子你会坐下来思考：如果我这么做，会让我和兄弟更亲近。你只是在感觉对的时候去做，你知道，你往往会做那些让你变得更亲近的事情。而我们做的那类事确实拉近了我们的关系。所以我们继续做那种事。
When I asked the other brothers if they'd do it all over again, they all say they would.
当我问其他兄弟他们是否愿意重来一次时，他们都说愿意。
Yeah, absolutely. I loved my childhood.
是的，绝对愿意。我热爱我的童年。
Even with all the terror and danger that was there, you would still do all of it over again?
即使有所有的恐惧和危险，你仍然愿意重来一次？
Absolutely, I look back on those years with complete fondness.
绝对愿意，我怀着完全的深情回顾那些岁月。
Hilary Frank. She's the host of The Longest Shortest Time, a podcast about early parenthood.
希拉里·弗兰克。她是《最长最短的时间》的主持人，这是一档关于早期父母身份的播客。
[SONG - THE PERFECT NANNY, MARY POPPINS]
[歌曲 - 完美的保姆，《玛丽·波平斯》]
John Langford of the Waco Brothers and the Micons with John Rice on mandolin, in a song recorded for our show. Whatever we are paying them, it is not enough. And this brings us to ACT 2.
John Langford of the Waco Brothers and the Micons，由John Rice弹奏曼陀林，这首歌是为我们的节目录制的。无论我们给他们多少酬劳，都不够。现在进入第二幕。
On the day after Christmas, all across America, divorced kids shuttle from one parent to the other. If they fly, their babysitters are the airlines themselves. This is babysitting encased in corporate procedure and corporate language, kids flying without adults are called unaccompanied minors. Little ones get brightly colored tags pinned to their coats or hung from their necks. When you see them, it's hard not to feel bad for them and wonder what they're going to say about the experience someday when they grow up.
圣诞节后的一天，全美各地的离异家庭孩子在父母之间往返。如果他们乘飞机，保姆就是航空公司本身。这是封装在企业程序和行话中的保姆服务，独自乘机的孩子被称为“无成人陪伴未成年人”。年幼的孩子身上贴着颜色鲜艳的标签，或者挂在脖子上。当你看到他们时，很难不对他们感到同情，并想知道他们长大后会如何评价这段经历。
Well, back in December of 1988, on December 26, divorced kids from all over the country got snowed in at O'Hare Airport here in Chicago. Susan Burton was one of those kids. Now old enough to tell the tale, she and her sister Betsy were traveling from Colorado where their mom lived to Michigan, where'd they'd grown up, and where their dad lived. Here's Susan.
好吧，回到1988年12月，12月26日，全国各地的离异孩子因大雪被困在芝加哥的奥黑尔机场。苏珊·伯顿就是其中之一。现在她年纪够大，可以讲述这个故事了。她和妹妹贝茜从妈妈居住的科罗拉多州前往她们成长地、爸爸所在的密歇根州。听听苏珊怎么说。
There were two types of unaccompanied minors on flights out of Denver-- divorced kids and skier kids. You could spot the skier kids because they always wore something to prove they'd been to Colorado. They had lift tickets fanning out from the zippers of their jackets, or baseball caps that said Vale. But since today it was December 26, we suspected that even the boy with the raccoon face tan, the kind you get from ski goggles, was like us, a divorced kid too.
从丹佛出发的航班上有两种“无成人陪伴未成年人”——离异家庭的孩子和滑雪的孩子。你可以认出那些滑雪的孩子，因为他们总是带着证明他们去过科罗拉多的东西。他们的夹克拉链上扇形展开着缆车票，或者戴着写着“维尔”字样的棒球帽。但因为今天是12月26日，我们怀疑即使是那个戴着像浣熊一样的护目镜晒痕的男孩，也像我们一样，是离异家庭的孩子。
As soon as our flight left Denver, my thoughts turned to our layover in Chicago. Betsy and I loved the O'Hare Airport, with its shiny food court, and chain bookstores, and big glass atrium ceiling. It seemed like a beautiful new mall. When we landed in Chicago, it was snowing, snowing hard enough to shut the airport down. It was only the middle of the afternoon, and travelers were already reserving sleeping spaces by throwing their parkas over blocks of chairs. Even floorspace was scarce. And some people were stuck alongside the moving walkway.
我们的航班离开丹佛后，我的思绪就转向了我们在芝加哥的转机。贝茜和我喜欢奥黑尔机场，它有闪亮的餐饮区、连锁书店和巨大的玻璃中庭天花板。它看起来像个漂亮的新购物中心。当我们降落在芝加哥时，雪下得很大，大到足以让机场关闭。那才下午，旅客们已经通过把大衣扔在几排椅子上预留睡觉的地方了。即使是地板空间也很稀缺。有些人甚至被困在自动步道旁边。
The mall had become a refugee camp. The departure board showed that our flight to Grand Rapids was canceled. So we went to a service desk, where an agent took our tickets and typed things into a terminal. Then she turned on her microphone and sent a cryptic message out over the PA. I have two UMs at the service desk, two UMs at the service desk. OK, the woman told us, someone's coming by for you. A second woman appeared and we followed her to a gray, unmarked door. She fumbled with her keys. I squeezed Betsy's hand.
这个购物中心变成了难民营。出发显示屏显示我们去大急流城的航班取消了。所以我们去了服务台，代理人拿走我们的机票，往终端机里输入东西。然后她打开麦克风，在广播里发出了神秘的信息。我在服务台有两名UM（无成人陪伴未成年人），服务台有两名UM。好了，那女人告诉我们，有人会来接你们。第二个女人出现了，我们跟着她走到一扇灰色、没有标记的门前。她摆弄着钥匙。我捏紧了贝茜的手。
The door opened onto a room packed with kids, sitting on their winter jackets. There were dozens of kids, all kinds of kids. Some in small groups. The young ones conversing with stuffed animals. Others looking uncomfortable in dresses, or overheated in moon boots that had been too big to pack. Most of them were facing a podium at the front of the room, as if they'd been dropped off at the public library and were waiting for a reading by Shel Silverstein. At the podium, a steward put our names on the list.
门打开，房间里挤满了坐在冬装外套上的孩子。有几十个孩子，各种各样的孩子。有些成群结队。年幼的在和毛绒玩具交谈。有的穿着裙子看起来很不舒服，或者在太大的雪地靴里感到闷热。他们大多数人面对着房间前方的讲台，好像他们被丢在公共图书馆，在等待谢尔·希尔弗斯坦的朗读会。在讲台上，乘务员把我们的名字记在名单上。
The woman standing next to him was wearing the uniform of another airline. It's strange to see people from different airlines mixing, almost like something that shouldn't be allowed. There were a handful of folding chairs in the room, and we found a free one near the center. I took the seat and Betsy settled on the floor beside me. She got her baby blanket out of her bag and began to sniff it. It seemed we'd never been around so many divorced kids at once. Back home, most kids had both parents.
站在他旁边的女人穿着另一家航空公司的制服。看到不同航空公司的人混在一起很奇怪，感觉像是某种不该被允许的事情。房间里有几把折叠椅，我们在中心附近找到一把空座。我坐下，贝茜在我身边地板上安顿下来。她从包里拿出婴儿毯开始闻。我们似乎从未被这么多离异家庭的孩子围住过。在家里，大多数孩子都有父母双方。
You'd forget you were different, and then you'd be at someone's house after school, and the dad would come home, and from the landing on the staircase, you'd see him sorting through the mail, talking to the mother in the kitchen. It was hard to explain why this was sad. As a result, all that most of our friends knew about our divorce was that my favorite video to rent was Kramer versus Kramer, and Betsy's was The Parent Trap. So now it was strange to hear kids talking about the things we kept for ourselves.
你会忘记自己与众不同，然后你会放学去别人家，爸爸回来了，你从楼梯平台上看到他在翻看邮件，和厨房里的母亲说话。很难解释为什么这很悲伤。结果，我们朋友们对我们父母离异的大多数了解，就是我最喜欢租的录像带是《克莱默夫妇》，而贝茜的是《天生一对》。所以现在听到孩子们谈论我们私藏的事情很奇怪。
A group nearby was engaged in a kind of divorced-kid one-upmanship. A girl wearing a sweatshirt with a Christmas tree patch said she saw her father only a couple of times a year. A boy lying on his stomach claimed that he saw his dad even less. They exchanged a series of anecdotes about stepmothers, and took a poll of who'd been the object of a custody battle. It seemed improper to talk so freely about these things. I had no way of expressing this at the time, but it felt like we were part of something on a grand scale. All these kids, here in Chicago, at the transfer point between mom and dad.
附近的一群人正在进行一种离异孩子之间的“比惨”。一个穿着带圣诞树补丁运动衫的女孩说她一年只见到父亲几次。一个躺着的男孩声称他见爸爸的次数更少。他们交换了一系列关于继母的轶事，并投票选出谁曾是监护权争夺战的对象。这样公开讨论这些事情似乎不太妥当。当时我无法表达这种感觉，但这让我觉得自己参与了某种大规模事件的一部分。所有的这些孩子，在这里，在芝加哥，在往返于妈妈和爸爸的转接点。
Being babysat by the airlines was a lot like what you'd expect. Gate agents started in and out, consulting papers, and making shushing noises, and yelling out names from the podium. They seemed flustered, annoyed. Normally, their babysitting duties were small scale. They were good at shepherding kids along moving walkways, and doling out little pins shaped like wings. In the UM room, they reverted to the same crowd control techniques that they used in flight-- secure the doors, withhold information, and discourage people from getting up to use the bathroom.
由航空公司照顾的感觉和你预料的差不多。登机口代理人进进出出，查阅文件，发出嘘声，在讲台上大声叫名字。他们看起来很慌乱、烦躁。通常，他们的保姆工作规模很小。他们擅长引导孩子走过自动步道，分发带有翅膀形状的小徽章。在UM房间里，他们恢复了在飞行中使用的那种人群控制技术——锁好门，隐瞒信息，阻止人们起身去洗手间。
So we did what any group of fed up delayed passengers does. We started to generate our own information. In the late evening, a rumor filtered through the crowd that the reason some kids were being escorted away was that their parents were making a bigger fuss than the other parents. Where were those kids going? The question arose from those of us in the landlocked middle and travelled through the crowd. The answer was transmitted back to us by our intelligence forces stationed at the podium. Those kids got hotels. The rest of us would have to sleep here in the UM room.
所以我们做了任何一群厌倦了延误的旅客会做的事。我们开始制造自己的信息。深夜，人群中传出一个谣言，说有些孩子被护送离开的原因是他们的父母比其他父母闹得更凶。那些孩子去了哪里？这个问题在陆地锁定的中心地带产生，并在人群中传播。答案由驻扎在讲台上的情报部队传回给我们。那些孩子得到了酒店。我们其余的人将不得不睡在这个UM房间里。
A divorced kid reacts to his parents' separation in one of two ways. As the rumor about the sleeping arrangements spread, it became clear who was the divorced kid who avoided conflict, and who was the divorced kid who acted out. Fart noises increased, crushed drink boxes began to litter the floor. I realized that when thrown with sufficient force, a Nerf ball could cause injury. Soon word came around that the system had changed, that our babysitters were mad, and they didn't care who your parents were or how many times they called. Now they were taking the good kids first. Immediately, Betsy lay down on her blanket. I took out the book in my bag, Catcher in the Rye. Within an hour, we were out of there. BY NOW IT WAS 1: 00 in the morning. Betsy and I, and a group of others, followed a stewardess through the dim halls. The metal gates were down over the entrance to the food court and travelers were sleeping in chairs. We would share a room with two other people. The first was a girl close to my age, who was wearing glasses with pink, plastic frames. I convinced myself that she was the same girl who had been in my line at swim camp years earlier, when my parents were still married. I didn't ask her because I didn't want to ruin it if it wasn't true.
离异的孩子对父母的分离有两种反应。随着关于睡觉安排的谣言传开，很明显谁是那个避免冲突的离异孩子，谁是那个表现得叛逆的离异孩子。放屁声增加，压扁的饮料盒开始堆满地板。我意识到，如果投掷力度足够大，Nerf球可能会造成伤害。很快有消息传出，系统变了，保姆们生气了，他们不在乎你的父母是谁，也不管他们打了多少次电话。现在他们先带走那些乖孩子。贝茜立刻躺在毯子上。我拿出包里的书，《麦田里的守望者》。一小时内，我们就出去了。现在已经凌晨1点了。贝茜、我和其他人跟着乘务员穿过昏暗的大厅。金属门在餐饮区入口处拉下，旅客们在椅子上睡觉。我们将和另外两个人共用一个房间。第一个是一个和我差不多大的女孩，戴着粉红色塑料框眼镜。我认定她就是几年前在游泳营排队时排在我前面的那个女孩，当时我父母还没有离婚。我没问她，因为如果不是真的，我不想毁了它。
The second person was a stewardess, who looked about 30. She wore a lot of makeup and she was big-boned, packed into her uniform. She wasn't mean to us. But she was pretty standoffish. We settled into our room. When the stewardess went into the bathroom, the swim camp girl pulled me over to the window. The curtains were closed, but red light shone in from the parking lot. Will you sleep in the bed with me, so I won't have to sleep with the stewardess, she said.
第二个人是一个乘务员，看起来30岁左右。她化了浓妆，骨架很大，塞进她的制服里。她对我们并不坏，但相当冷漠。我们在房间安顿下来。当乘务员进浴室时，那个游泳营女孩把我拉到窗边。窗帘拉着，但停车场透进红光。她说，你愿意跟我睡在那张床上吗，这样我就不用和那个乘务员睡了。
I looked over at Betsy. She was sitting on one of the two double beds in the room, sniffing her blanket. I told the girl yes. It just came out. Almost immediately I felt awful. When we lay down, I inched as far to the edge as I could, so that I'd feel nearer to my sister on the edge of the bed across the aisle. The stewardess came out of the bathroom wearing control top stockings and a lacy slip and got under the covers like that. I'd never seen a grown woman sleep in anything other than a flannel nightgown.
我看向贝茜。她坐在房间两张双人床之一上，闻着她的毯子。我告诉那个女孩“愿意”。这话脱口而出。我立刻感到难受。当我们躺下时，我尽可能往边缘挪，这样就能感觉到靠近走廊另一边床上的妹妹。乘务员穿着控制紧身袜和蕾丝衬裙从浴室出来，就那样钻进被子里。我从未见过成年女性穿着法兰绒睡衣以外的东西睡觉。
I wondered if she always slept like that, or it was just because she had to get up early. Maybe this was what all stewardesses wore under their uniform. But maybe she just felt awkward. Or maybe there were rules about what you wore, that you had to keep covered. Or maybe she just didn't want her bare legs near Betsy. I saw Betsy shift under the covers and curl into a ball. I now felt certain that this was the worst thing I'd ever done to my sister. I wanted the strangers removed and my family restored.
我想知道她是不是总是那样睡觉，还是因为她得早起。也许这就是所有乘务员穿在制服里的衣服。但也许她只是觉得尴尬。或者也许关于穿什么有规定，必须保持遮盖。或者也许她只是不想让她的光腿靠近贝茜。我看到贝茜在被子里挪动，蜷缩成一团。我现在确定这是我对我妹妹做过的最糟糕的事。我想让这些陌生人离开，让我的家庭恢复原样。
I hated the swim camp girl sleeping next to me. She wasn't from Michigan. She didn't have anything to do with my life. On these trips to visit our father, more than any other time, all Betsy and I had was each other. I thought of the kids in the UM room at the airport, the ones saying crass things about the saddest thing that had ever happened in life. And how reassuring it had been when I looked at Betsy, sniffing her blanket, the way she always had, the way I thought she would forever.
我恨那个睡在我旁边的游泳营女孩。她不是密歇根人。她和我的生活没有任何关系。在这些去看望父亲的旅途中，比任何其他时候都多，贝茜和我只有彼此。我想到了机场UM房间里的那些孩子，那些对生命中最悲伤的事发表粗俗言论的孩子。当我看着贝茜闻着她的毯子时，那种感觉是多么令人安心，就像她一直以来那样，就像我以为她永远会那样。
Susan Burton-- in the years since that story was first broadcast on our radio show, a movie based on that story, about kids of divorce, trapped in an airport over Christmas, was released. It was in 2006. It was a kids' comedy directed by Paul Feig. It was called Unaccompanied Minors.
苏珊·伯顿——在那篇故事首次在我们的广播节目中播出几年后，一部基于那个故事、关于离异家庭孩子在圣诞节被困机场的电影上映了。那是2006年。那是一部由保罗·费格执导的儿童喜剧。名字叫《无成人陪伴未成年人》。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放]
- We have our own suggestions for the new nanny. Would you like to hear them?
- 我们对新保姆有自己的建议。你想听听吗？
- You have my undivided attention.
- 我洗耳恭听。
- Maestro, if you please.
- 老师，请开始吧。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
- If you wish to be our sitter, please be sweet, and never bitter. Help us with math and book reports. Might I add eat my shorts.
- 如果你愿做我们的保姆，请甜美点，别苦着脸。帮我们做数学和书面报告。我能加一句吗，去死吧。
- Bart.
- 巴特。
- Just cutting through the treacle.
- 只是抛开这些甜腻的东西。
- If Maggie's fussy, don't avoid her.
- 如果玛吉吵闹，别躲着她。
- Let me get away with murder.
- 让我为所欲为。
- The nanny we want is kindly and sage.
- 我们想要的保姆要和蔼、睿智。
- And one who will work for minimum wage.
- 还要愿意拿最低工资。
[END PLAYBACK]
[回放结束]
Coming up, how hard could it be to babysit kids who do not even exist? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，照顾那些根本不存在的孩子会有多难？芝加哥公共广播电台将在稍后的节目中继续播出。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, babysitting and what happens that mom and dad do not find out about. Today's program was first broadcast back in 2001. We've arrived at Act 3 of our program.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种故事。今天节目的主题是“保姆以及那些父母不会发现的事情”。今天的节目首播于2001年。现在进入我们节目的第三幕。
This is a story that caught our interest because of babysitting, but then it ended up being about so many other things besides. A man in Florida named Myron Jones wrote us this letter. He said that when he was 16 years old, growing up without a dad in Buffalo, New York, he was allowed to stay out till midnight.
这是一个因为保姆工作引起我们兴趣的故事，但最终它变成了关于许多其他事情的故事。佛罗里达州的一位名叫迈伦·琼斯的男士给我们写了这封信。他说当他16岁时，在纽约州布法罗市过着没有父亲的生活，他被允许玩到午夜。
He came and went as he pleased. Spent a lot of time in bars, actually. This was the 1940s. But his sister Carol, she had different rules, and she wasn't let out of the house at all, even though she was older than Myron. This story gets to babysitting in a big, big way. And I called him to talk about it.
他随心所欲，经常泡吧，其实那是20世纪40年代。但他妹妹卡罗尔有不同的规定，尽管她比迈伦大，却根本不被允许出门。这个故事深刻地触及了保姆的话题。我打电话给他聊了聊。
She had to say exactly where she was going, who she was going with. She could go to church dances, but only some church dances. It all had to do with protecting her chastity, really.
她必须确切地说去哪，和谁去。她可以去教会舞会，但只能去其中的一些。这其实都与保护她的贞操有关。
If one were to ask your mother at the time, what would she have said?
如果当时去问你母亲，她会怎么说？
She said you've got to be more careful with the girls.
她说你必须对女孩子更加小心。
Yeah.
是啊。
Spelled P-R-E-G-N-A-N-T. So my sister figured out a little scheme. She invented a family called the McCrearys. Said they needed her to babysit. And I remember when she first told me about it. She said listen, guess what I did, I made up a family. I said what do you mean? I made up this family I babysit for, they're called the McCrearys.
拼写为P-R-E-G-N-A-N-T。所以妹妹想出了一个小计划。她编造了一个叫麦克里里的家庭。说是他们需要她当保姆。我记得她第一次跟我说的时候。她说听着，猜猜我做了什么，我编造了一个家庭。我说什么意思？我编了一个保姆家庭，他们叫麦克里里一家。
It seemed clear once I got talking to Myron Jones that his sister Carol, might have a few thoughts about all this. And we gave her a call. She agreed to go into a studio and chat. She says if anything, her brother was understanding just how strict the mother was with her.
在和迈伦·琼斯交谈后，我很清楚他妹妹卡罗尔可能对这一切有些想法。我们打电话联系了她。她同意去录音室聊聊。她说，如果有的话，她哥哥很理解母亲对她有多严厉。
She used to follow me. She had a friend. We called them Sam Spade and the fat man. And they would follow us. And then I'd go home, and she'd come in and say where have you been. It was-- it was really, really hard. She didn't believe anything I ever said.
她以前经常跟踪我。她有一个朋友。我们叫他们“萨姆·斯佩德”和“胖子”。他们会跟踪我们。然后我回家，她会进来问我去哪了。这真的、真的很艰难。她不相信我说的一切。
And were you a pretty good kid, good student in school?
你当时是个好孩子、好学生吗？
I was, you know, for a long time I thought that, oh, I was terrible. My mother started calling me a whore before I had any idea what the word was. And I couldn't look it up, because it didn't know it was spelled. I couldn't find it.
是的，你知道，很长一段时间我都认为，哦，我太糟糕了。我妈妈在我还没概念那词是什么意思时，就开始骂我是妓女。我没法查字典，因为不知道怎么拼。找不到那个词。
Wow.
天哪。
And so, it occurred to me that if I had a family, a non-existent family, I could go, I could say I was going there.
所以，我想如果我有一个家庭，一个不存在的家庭，我就可以出门，说我是去那儿。
Carol started working out the details. Because whenever she babysat, my mother had to have the phone number so she could check up on her. So the man in the family was an FBI agent, working on a top secret project, so he could not give his phone number to anyone at all. He also couldn't let anyone but my sister, the babysitter, know just where they lived. It would have been dangerous for him to do so.
卡罗尔开始制定细节。因为每当她当保姆时，我妈妈都得要电话号码，以便查岗。所以家庭里的那个男人是一个联邦调查局特工，从事一个绝密项目，所以他根本不能把电话号码给任何人。他也不能让除我妹妹（保姆）以外的任何人知道他们住在哪里。告诉别人会有危险。
So, how far did this go? How complicated did the story of the McCrearys get?
那么，这件事发展到什么程度？关于麦克里里一家的故事有多复杂？
It got very complicated. They had two kids. Michael was three and Laura was two. That happened to be the age separation between my sister and myself, but it was reversed. Sometimes the little boy in particular would try to test us. And I'd let him get away with it. But my sister wouldn't. And they had all kinds of toys, but not too many toys. And they liked their parents very much, loved their parents. They were easy, they weren't spoiled in any way.
变得非常复杂。他们有两个孩子。迈克尔三岁，劳拉两岁。这正好是我妹妹和我之间的年龄差距，但顺序颠倒了。有时小男孩特别会考验我们。我会让他得逞。但我妹妹不会。他们有各种各样的玩具，但又不是太多。他们非常爱他们的父母。他们很乖，一点也不被娇惯。
They sound like very special kids.
他们听起来是很特别的孩子。
Oh, yeah, they were great. They were like no kids I ever met really. I think, I think in many ways they had the life my sister wished that we'd had.
哦，是的，他们很棒。他们不像我见过的任何孩子。我觉得，在很多方面，他们拥有我妹妹希望我们拥有的生活。
I had them rent a cottage at the lake for the summer.
我让他们在夏天租了湖边的小屋。
So the McCrearys had a summer house.
所以麦克里里一家有避暑别墅。
Yes.
是的。
And did they require your services at the summer house?
他们在避暑别墅也需要你的服务吗？
Yes, indeed. They knew that the kids would enjoy it so much more if we were there. And it was we, because both my brother and I always liked little kids a lot, you know. So my mother would accept this quite readily, you know, that they wanted the both of us out at the lake. It was wonderful. We had such a good summer. I mean, it was glorious.
确实。他们知道如果我们也在那儿，孩子们会开心得多。是我们，因为我哥哥和我一直都很喜欢小孩子，你知道。所以我妈妈很容易接受这一点，你知道，他们想让我们俩都去湖边。太棒了。我们度过了一个美好的夏天。我是说，真是辉煌。
What would you do?
你们会做什么？
Well, we just-- sometimes if we knew someone out there-- sometimes kids we knew would have cottages, you know kids used to get together and chip in, or their parents would have a cottage. Sometimes we'd just sleep on the beach, which was great. I'd love sleeping on the beach.
好吧，我们就——如果我们认识那里的人——有时我们认识的孩子会有小屋，你知道孩子们过去常聚在一起凑钱，或者他们的父母有小屋。有时我们就睡在沙滩上，那太棒了。我喜欢睡在沙滩上。
I have to say every time you talk about the freedom you got, your voice becomes completely different. It's like you can still taste it.
我不得不说，每次你谈到你得到的自由，你的声音就变得完全不同。就像你还能尝到那种滋味。
I still remember what that was like. It offered freedom that was just so wonderful to me.
我还记得那是什么感觉。它带给我的自由对我来说真是太美妙了。
We really got all of this from our mother, this notion of fantasy people. Our mother had, from the time we were young kids, younger than 10, our mother had three people that she went to see. None of them existed, and we always knew they didn't exist.
我们真的是从妈妈那里学到了这些关于虚构人物的概念。从我们很小的时候，不到10岁起，妈妈就有三个她要去见的“人”。他们都不存在，而我们一直都知道他们不存在。
Really?
真的？
Yeah.
是啊。
Who were they?
他们是谁？
One was a lawyer. And she wouldn't say what she was doing there, but she'd drop little hints. And what we were supposed to believe was that was making arrangements to put us in an orphanage. The second person she saw was a psychiatrist, which she pronounced psycholorgist-- interesting. And she went there because he would tell her that we were driving her crazy.
一个是律师。她不会说她在那里做什么，但会透露一点点暗示。我们要相信的是，她正在做安排把我们送进孤儿院。第二个她见的“人”是心理医生，她发音为“心理学教授”——有意思。她去找他是因为他会告诉她，是我们让她发疯了。
I see.
我明白了。
And the third person was a doctor, who told her she was going to die. And we had no idea where in fact she went, but she was never gone long enough to see anyone at all.
第三个是一个医生，告诉她她快死了。我们根本不知道她实际上去了哪里，但她从没走开过足够长的时间去见任何人。
So in other words, she would literally-- this wasn't just something she would say to you, well, I've been to a psychiatrist and he tells me that you're driving-- that you guys are driving me crazy. She would actually leave the house and go to her appointment.
也就是说，她实际上会——这不仅仅是她会对你们说的话，比如“我见过心理医生了，他说你们让我发疯了”。她真的会离开家去赴约。
Yeah, she'd say-- she'd say-- she'd go for the door, and when we were young, we'd say where you going, Ma, because it was so unusual for her to go out, except to work. And she'd say wouldn't you like to know? Oh, OK. Is it your doctor? As we got older, she'd say, maybe. And so that was her game.
是的，她会说——她会说——她走向门口，当我们还小时，我们会说妈妈你去哪儿，因为除了上班，她很少出门。她会说，难道你想知道吗？哦，好的。是去看医生吗？随着我们长大，她会说，也许吧。这就是她的游戏。
In retrospect, where do you think she was going?
回顾过去，你认为她去了哪里？
I have no idea. I think she walked around the block a couple of times.
我不知道。我觉得她可能绕着街区走了几圈。
So at some point, your mother must have wanted to meet them, right?
那么在某个时候，你妈妈肯定想见他们，对吧？
No, she was-- shy isn't the word for her. But she didn't like knowing people at all. She didn't know the people next door. She didn't want to know them. So she was really deliberately isolated. But the McCrearys were far and away her favorite topic of conversation. My mother would ask questions about them. And then Carol would give her far more information and she asked for.
不，她——用“害羞”形容她都不够。但她根本不喜欢认识人。她甚至不认识隔壁邻居。她不想认识任何人。所以她是真的很刻意地与世隔绝。但麦克里里一家是她最喜欢谈论的话题。我妈会问关于他们的问题。然后卡罗尔会提供比她要求的更多的信息。
Say more of what you remember of what she would tell her.
多说说你还记得她会告诉她什么。
Well, one was that Mrs. McCreary was very intelligent, and lovely, and very kind. She was my sister's fantasy of a mother. And she was my fantasy of an older woman who might fall in love with me, and with any luck at all seduce me.
嗯，其中之一是麦克里里夫人非常聪明，可爱，非常善良。她是我妹妹心中母亲的幻想。而她也是我心中年长女性的幻想，可能会爱上我，如果运气好还能诱惑我。
So wait, would you talk about it with your mom too?
等等，你也会和妈妈谈论这个吗？
Yeah, my sister started that. I was a little uncomfortable about it. My sister said I think he's got a crush on her. And I would almost blush, uncomfortably, because I did.
是的，是我妹妹开始的。我当时有点不自在。我妹妹说，我觉得他对她有好感。我几乎会不舒服地脸红，因为我确实有。
And then your mom would ask you questions. For example, what color hair does she have?
然后你妈妈会问你问题。比如，她是什么颜色的头发？
No, she didn't ask questions like that. She never asked questions like that.
不，她从不问那样的问题。她从来不问那种问题。
So what would she ask?
那她会问什么？
She'd say, well, I hope you act right over there. What do they think of you? And then the question she to this day asks, well, what do they think of your mother? And Carol would say, give the right answer, which is they think you're wonderful, mom. It was a way of having a conversation with her.
她会说，好吧，我希望你在那儿表现得好。他们怎么看你？然后她至今还会问的问题是：好吧，他们怎么看你妈妈？卡罗尔会给出正确的回答，也就是“他们觉得你很棒，妈妈”。这是一种和她对话的方式。
And a kind of in-depth conversation.
而且是一种深入的对话。
That's right. She liked to hear about fancy people. She imagined somehow that it would all rub off on Carol.
没错。她喜欢听关于那些体面人的事。她想象着某种程度上这一切会感染卡罗尔。
That they'd be a good influence somehow.
他们会产生好的影响。
They'd be a good influence and there might even be some money in it. Carol also handled-- because she wasn't getting any money from babysitting, she said that Mr. McCreary was taking all the babysitting money and putting it into stocks and bonds.
他们会产生好的影响，甚至可能还有些钱。卡罗尔还处理了——因为她没从当保姆那里拿到钱，她说麦克里里先生把所有的保姆费都拿去投资股票和债券了。
Wait, wait, hold it, just back up.
等等，等等，停一下，重来。
Yeah, Carol knew she was going to ask, so she anticipated it. Carol said, before it could even come up, Carol said Mr. McCreary isn't going to pay me. He's going to pay all my babysitting money into stocks and bonds. My mother didn't know anything about stocks and bonds, and neither did we. But my mother knew that that's what rich people did. And it was over on the other side of town, the rich side of town.
是的，卡罗尔知道她会问，所以她预判了。卡罗尔说，在问题出来之前，卡罗尔就说麦克里里先生不给我现金，他会把所有的钱都投到股票和债券里。我妈妈对股票和债券一无所知，我们也不知道。但我妈妈知道富人就是这么做的。而且那是在城市的另一边，富人区。
Right.
对。
My mother didn't know anything about that neighborhood. She was the oldest of seven children, grew up in a very really poor family. My mother had one friend who was middle class, who she'd met when my father was still alive. And she influenced my mother. And so did the people that my mother cleaned for.
我妈妈对那个街区一无所知。她是七个孩子中的老大，在非常贫穷的家庭长大。我妈妈有一个中产阶级的朋友，是我父亲去世前认识的。她影响了我妈妈。我妈妈曾经打扫过的人家也影响了她。
At the end of the summer, it was the last weekend. And that was near the real change in the McCreary time.
暑假快结束时，是最后一个周末。那接近麦克里里时光真正的转折点。
Well, what happened at the end of the summer?
暑假最后发生了什么？
We really were exhausted from our summer, from our real summer weekends.
我们真的是从我们的暑假中精疲力竭了，从我们真正的暑假周末中。
The strenuous work of having fun with your friends.
和朋友玩耍的艰苦工作。
Yeah, right. And those times when there was no cottage to go to, and we'd sleep out on the beach, and we were going home, and we headed up the back stairs. We always had to go in the back way. We headed up the back stairs, and we'd go to the second floor.
是的，对。那些没有小屋可去、睡在沙滩上的时光，我们回家，走向后楼梯。我们总是必须走后面那条路。我们走上后楼梯，来到二楼。
And we could tell before we turned the corner that our mother was outside the door, waiting for us. And we turned, and there she was. And she looked ready to kill. She looked absolutely furious. She said well, where you too been? And I though, oh, god, she found out all about the summer cottage stuff.
还没转弯我们就知道妈妈在门口等着我们。我们转过去，她真的在那儿。她看起来准备杀人了。她看起来绝对狂怒。她说，你们俩去哪儿了？我心想，哦天哪，她发现了关于度假小屋的事。
And Carol said, you know where we've been, ma, at the McCrearys. And my mother said, oh, yeah. Well, you're a couple of damn liars. I just got off the phone with Mrs. McCreary. She hasn't seen you in weeks.
卡罗尔说，你知道我们在哪儿，妈，在麦克里里家。我妈说，哦，是吗。好吧，你们俩是该死的骗子。我刚给麦克里里夫人打完电话。她几周都没见过你们了。
My brother and I agree, we didn't breathe. We thought, oh, my god, she's talked to them. And then as quickly, we realized, of course she didn't talk to them.
我哥哥和我当时没敢呼吸。我们心想，哦天哪，她跟他们通过话了。然后我们立刻意识到，她当然没跟他们通话。
Carol got over it immediately, and said, sorry, Ma. Nice try. We just left the McCrearys 10 minutes ago. Went in the house. She didn't say anything to us, we didn't say anything to her. And after that, we really stopped talking about the McCrearys.
卡罗尔立刻反应过来，说，抱歉，妈。不错的尝试。我们10分钟前才离开麦克里里家。进了屋。她什么也没对我们说，我们也没对她说什么。在那之后，我们就真的不再谈论麦克里里一家了。
Did she often claimed that she had run into the McCrearys?
她是否经常声称她偶遇过麦克里里一家？
Yes, that she'd talked to her, that she hadn't seen me. She did it so often. She believed this. It was amazing, but she never questioned these things.
是的，说她跟她谈过话，没见过我。她经常这样做。她相信这是真的。这很惊人，但她从不质疑这些事。
Why do you think she didn't question it?
你认为她为什么不质疑？
I think she wanted it to be true, probably as much as I did.
我认为她想让这一切是真的，可能和我一样想。
It's interesting, when you invented-- when you invented them, it's as if you invented them in terms that would reassure your mom.
很有趣，当你编造他们时，就像你编造他们是为了安抚你妈妈一样。
Yeah, I probably did. I don't think that-- well, you know, it did. I'm sure it did occur to me that I wanted a family that would please her.
是的，我可能确实是。我不认为——好吧，你知道，确实是。我相信我当时确实想到我想要一个能让她高兴的家庭。
Is that because-- is that because it would make her more likely to let you out? Or was there a part of it where you also were the kind of kid where you always needed to be reassuring her anyway?
这是因为——这是因为这会让这让她更可能放你出门？还是说你也是那种总是需要安抚她的孩子？
Oh, I had to constantly reassure her, always. I mean, it isn't something I talk easily about, but she really never liked me. That was the problem.
哦，我必须不断地安抚她，总是这样。我是说，这不是我容易谈论的话题，但她真的从来没喜欢过我。那才是问题所在。
Is your mom still alive?
你妈妈还活着吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So how old is she now?
她现在多大了？
94.
94岁。
How old are you?
你多大了？
I'm going to be 70 in another 10 days.
再过10天我就要70岁了。
So have you ever come clean with her on this?
所以你从来没跟她摊牌过这件事？
Oh, no, never. Do you want me to make my mother look like a liar?
哦，不，从不。你想让我让我母亲看起来像个骗子吗？
In the sense, you already have. It's just a question of whether she's going to know it.
从某种意义上说，你已经做了。问题只是她是否会知道。
Right. No, it never crossed my mind to do it.
对。不，我从来没想过这么做。
Are you serious? It's never crossed your mind?
你是认真的吗？你从来没想过？
To tell her? No, never.
去告诉她？不，从来没有。
Because she wouldn't be able to laugh about it, it sounds like.
因为听起来她不会对此一笑置之。
Not in any way. She might simply say that we were lying now, that there were McCrearys and we were just saying that for some reason.
根本不会。她可能会简单地说我们现在在撒谎，其实真的有麦克里里一家，我们只是为了某种原因才那么说的。
Does it make you sad that you can't have the kind of relationship with your mom, where now that everyone's an adult, you know, you can't come straight with all of it?
想到你不能和你妈妈建立那种关系，想到大家都成年了，却不能坦诚地面对这一切，你会感到难过吗？
No, my sister and I-- I think because of, because of going away to school when I was so young-- let me back up a little bit. When I was nine, I came home on a Saturday afternoon, and my mother said, I'm sorry you weren't here, because Father Sager, who was an Episcopal priest, was here visiting. And he found a very nice orphanage for you.
不，我和我妹妹——我认为是因为，因为我那么小就去住校了——让我倒带一下。当我9岁时，我周六下午回家，我妈妈说，真可惜你不在家，因为萨格神父（一位圣公会牧师）来访。他为你找到了一个很好的孤儿院。
And I said, but I'm not an orphan, Ma. She said, no, I know. I told Father Sager that. But he said, really you are, because I have to work all the time, and there's no one to take care of you. And I said, well, we take care of ourselves. And she said, I need to tell Father Sager that, but he said, not really. You go there, it'll be a good place for you. You go there.
我说，但我不是孤儿，妈。她说，不，我知道。我告诉萨格神父了。但他确实说，你实际上是，因为我必须一直工作，没人照顾你。我说，好吧，我们自己照顾自己。她说，我得告诉萨格神父那样，但他确实说，并不真的。你去那儿吧，那对你是个好地方。你去吧。
I was close to-- I was in my 30s before I understood why I went away to school when I was 10. I didn't have to. I could have not gone. I could have screwed up the test. I could have gone and gotten kicked out right away. I knew that. One of the things that our mother did with us, from the time we were very young.
我快——我在30多岁时才明白为什么我在10岁时去住校了。我本不必去的。我可以不去。我可以搞砸考试。我可以去然后直接被开除。我知道这些。这是我妈妈从我们很小时就一直对我们做的事。
I can't remember before, but I know before I went to school, my mother used to say to us, when your father died, everybody told me to put the two of you in an orphanage. I didn't, and that was the biggest mistake of my life. So when the day came, I came home, and she said, Father Sager found an orphanage for you, what I really did was say, you've been threatening me with this all my life, and now, damn it, I'm going to go.
我不记得更早的事，但我知道在我去学校之前，妈妈常对我们说，你父亲去世时，所有人都让我把你们俩送进孤儿院。我没送，那是这辈子最大的错误。所以那一天到来时，我回家，她说萨格神父为你找到了一个孤儿院，我当时其实是说，你这一辈子都在用这个威胁我，现在，该死的，我要去。
Yeah.
是啊。
And it felt safer. I was scared as hell. I was one of two kids in the sixth grade. The other kid never showed up. I went to all classes alone for six weeks. And after six weeks, I went home. And I was-- it was late October, already dark in Buffalo, and around supper time. And I was walking down the street, and I loved my neighborhood. I knew everybody. I looked, and the lights were on, thinking it's warm in there. That's people-- that's Sonny Calucci's house. That's his house. They're in there. And I have a house too.
感觉更安全了。我当时吓坏了。我是六年级仅有的两个孩子之一。另一个孩子没来。我有六周时间独自上所有的课。六周后，我回家了。当时是10月下旬，布法罗天已经黑了，正值晚餐时间。我走在街上，我爱我的街区。我认识每一个人。我看了一眼，灯亮着，心想里面真暖和。那是桑尼·卡卢奇的家。那是他的家。他们在里面。我也有一个家。
I go to school now, but I have a house too. And I'm almost there. And I walked in the door, and I started to hug my mother. And my mother put out her hand to hold me back, and said, now, let me ask you a question. When you're up there at that fancy school, do you ever think about your mother, lying here in bed, crying her eyes out every single night? You ever think about that? Nah, you never think about anybody but yourself. And I literally from that moment on have never asked my mother for anything, never looked to her for anything.
我现在虽然去上学，但我也有一个家。我就快到了。我走进门，开始拥抱我妈妈。我妈妈伸出手挡住我，说，现在，让我问你个问题。当你在那所高级学校时，你有没有想过你妈妈，每天晚上躺在床上哭得死去活来？你有没有想过？不，你从来只关心你自己。从那一刻起，我确实再也没向我妈要求过任何事，再也没指望她过什么。
How old were you then?
你那时多大？
I was 10.
10岁。
Through the years, I have truly envied him that he has been able to do that, and that I have been unable to do that, not believing that I'm going to get anything from her. I know I haven't. But I have never, I haven't been able to this moment to just take her out of my life completely.
这些年来，我真地很羡慕他，因为他能够做到那样，而我却做不到，我无法做到不相信能从她那里得到什么。我知道我得不到。但我到现在为止还不能彻底把她从我的生活中剔除。
How often do you see her now?
你现在多久见她一次？
Do I see her?
我见她？
Yeah.
是啊。
I'm now seeing her twice a week. I mean, I call her every night, which is all something to do with me. Because she doesn't know that I call her every night.
我现在每周见她两次。我是说，我每天晚上都给她打电话，这和我自己有关。因为她不知道我每天晚上都给她打电话。
Because she's becoming senile?
因为她开始老年痴呆了吗？
Yes.
是的。
What do you think you've gotten by being the one caring for her?
你认为照顾她让你得到了什么？
One time, when I was 35, I lashed out at her in such a way, and told her how I felt about her, and she sat in a chair in the kitchen, and she was crying. And I had never even seen her cry before. And when I finally stopped talking, she said, I did the very best I could. And I thought, oh, my god, she did. Her best was so bad. Her best was so empty. But she couldn't do any better.
有一次，当我35岁时，我那样对她大发雷霆，告诉她我对她的感受，她坐在厨房的椅子上，哭了。我以前甚至没见过她哭。当我终于停下来说话时，她说，我真的是尽力了。我想，哦，天哪，她确实尽力了。她的“尽力”是那么糟糕。她的“尽力”是那么空洞。但她做不到更好。
I decided, and it helps me a lot-- I have a great aunt that I just adored, and her mother, my mother's mother, who was wonderful, and my great-grandmother, who I didn't know, but who adored my mother, my mother slept in bed with her, I thought I'm going to do this for the people that loved her, you know, all of the people that really loved this little girl, I'm going to do it for them. And it feels-- that feels fine to me.
我决定了，这对我帮助很大——我有一位我崇拜的姨婆，她的母亲，我妈妈的母亲，她很好，还有我的曾外祖母，我不认识她，但她很疼爱我妈妈，我妈妈是和她睡在一起的，我想我要为那些爱她的人做这件事，你知道，所有那些真正爱过这个小女孩的人，我要为他们去做。这感觉——这对我来说感觉很好。
You know what you're describing is you and your sister going off and pretending to babysit for these imaginary kids. But in fact, you guys had a babysitting job, and it was for your mom.
你知道你所描述的是你和你妹妹跑去假装给那些虚构的孩子当保姆。但事实上，你们有一个保姆工作，那是为了你们的妈妈。
That's right. My sister was the chief babysitter. It's true.
没错。我妹妹是首席保姆。是真的。
At the time, when you were kids, did you-- when you were kids, did you ever see it that way? Oh, we're taking care of mom. She thinks she's taking care of us, but we're taking care of her?
那时，当你们还是孩子时，你们——当你们还是孩子时，你们有没有这样想过？哦，我们在照顾妈妈。她以为她在照顾我们，但其实我们在照顾她？
Oh, yeah. There was a kind of humoring her, and placating her. And when I was about 10, she gave me a first baseman's glove, because I was going to be a major league ball player when I grew up. And she said, you tell people who gave you the glove? I said yeah. You tell them how much it cost? I didn't, but I said, yeah. She said, you tell them how long I had to work to buy that? I said, yeah. She said, you did not.
哦，是的。有一种哄着她、安抚她的感觉。我大约10岁时，她给了我一只一垒手手套，因为我长大后要成为大联盟球员。她说，你告诉别人手套是谁给的吗？我说，告诉了。你告诉他们这花了多少钱吗？我没告诉，但我说，说了。她说，你告诉他们我得工作多久才能买下这个吗？我说，说了。她说，你根本没说。
Let's set the record straight. Here we go, you're on the radio. How long did your mother have to work to buy you the baseball glove?
让我们把真相搞清楚。好了，你在广播里。你妈妈得工作多久才能给你买那个棒球手套？
She had to work a week.
她得工作一个星期。
That's a long time.
那是很长的时间。
Absolutely, I've thought about it since then. Have I ever given my kids a present that was worth a week's wages? No, I haven't.
绝对是，从那以后我一直在想。我有没有给我的孩子们买过一份价值一周工资的礼物？不，没有。
Mr. Jones, what would have happened if there hadn't been the McCrearys?
琼斯先生，如果没有麦克里里一家会怎样？
The McCrearys seemed absolutely inevitable. I never thought about what would happen if they hadn't been there.
麦克里里一家似乎绝对是不可避免的。我从未想过如果没有他们会怎样。
Wow.
天哪。
They had to be there. I still think we would be in-- let's see, they would be 56, 57 years old now. I've wondered where they're living, how they're doing?
他们必须存在。我仍然认为我们会在——让我看看，他们现在应该是56、57岁了。我很好奇他们住在哪里，过得怎么样？
Where do you picture them?
你脑海里他们是什么样子？
I picture them doing very well. And kind of dull now.
我脑海里他们过得很好。而且现在很无趣。
Really.
真的？
Yeah. I don't picture them as being terribly interesting. They're more conservative than their parents. But nice, pleasant, good people.
是啊。我不觉得他们特别有趣。他们比他们的父母更保守。但他们是很好、很愉快、善良的人。
Where do you think they're living?
你觉得他们住在哪里？
I'm afraid I think they're living in Florida.
恐怕我觉得他们住在佛罗里达州。
They are, not too far from where you are.
他们就在那里，离你不太远。
I may run into them in the store.
我可能会在店里遇到他们。
Myron and Carol said there was no way their mother would ever hear this story on the radio. And the fact is she never did. The story was first broadcast in 2001. She died at the age of 95 in 2002. After she died, Carol told Myron this secret that she had promised her mother she would never tell him.
迈伦和卡罗尔说，他们的母亲绝不可能在广播里听到这个故事。事实是，她确实从来没听到过。这个故事最初于2001年播出。她于2002年以95岁高龄去世。她去世后，卡罗尔告诉了迈伦这个她曾承诺母亲永远不会告诉他的秘密。
It turns out her mom didn't actually buy that baseball glove for Myron. Their uncle bought the glove. And when it arrived at the house wrapped as a gift, Myron's mom intercepted it, gave it to him, and pretended it was from her all along. Carol lives in California. Myron, who was a model of grace and good humor in that interview, died in 2011 at the age of 80. Lovely man.
原来她妈妈并没有真的给迈伦买那个棒球手套。是他们的叔叔买了那个手套。当它作为礼物送到家里时，迈伦的妈妈把它截获了，给了他，并一直假装是她买的。卡罗尔住在加州。在采访中表现出优雅和幽默的迈伦于2011年去世，享年80岁。可爱的人。
[SONG - THE PERFECT NANNY, MARY POPPINS]
[歌曲 - 完美的保姆，《玛丽·波平斯》]
Today's program of our show was produced by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Blue Chevigny, Jonathan Goldstein, Starlee Kine, Julie Snyder, and Erin Yanke. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production up for today's show by BA Parker.
今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，参与者有布鲁·切维尼、乔纳森·戈德斯坦、斯塔莉·凯恩、朱莉·斯奈德和艾琳·扬克。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。今天节目的制作由BA帕克完成。
Quick program note, a couple weeks ago, we had an excerpt from Jon Ronson's new podcast, The Butterfly Effect, on our program. He has been one of my favorite interviewers anywhere, a wonderful writer. And his podcast has just been released. If you want to hear it, it's an audible.com/butterfly. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
快速节目预告，几周前，我们在节目中播出了乔恩·罗森的新播客《蝴蝶效应》的节选。他是但我最喜欢的采访者之一，是一位出色的作家。他的播客刚刚发布。如果你想听，地址是audible.com/butterfly。我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He still asks me after every single show, you tell them how much it cost? You tell them how long I had to work to buy that? You did not.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换台）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他仍然在每一场演出后问我，你告诉他们那花了多少钱吗？你告诉他们我得工作多久才能买下它吗？你根本没说。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多的故事。
[MUSIC]
[音乐]